reject nation greg and john here today
we are going to watch what if episode 6
today if you're a fan of michael b
jordan go ahead and hit that like button
today subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction for what if is up as
always full length watch as long as we
sync up with the time code will be
available over at our patreon page we
cover a whole bunch of shows over there
with the same tier you get the option
for reaction highlights and watch along
included i really wanted to say though
happy birthday to koi zhandro it is his
birthday right now as we are filming
this as a matter of fact let me send him
a text so i'm a good friend john don't
be a follower lastly thank you to
berthom gindalf writing down these
highlights for us anywho guys let's
swing on an action
[Music]
every journey has a beginning
but change
he was so close to us that time yeah in
full color
that was a spectacular entrance
seriously the ten rings have
reinforcements in route we need to move
now mine by me
killed monger what is that german a
nickname
clearly a good fit i see where they got
it
without tony stark's fateful capture in
afghanistan the age of iron man
obadiah i saw young americans killed by
the very weapons i created to protect
them and i realized we have to do better
build bigger and fight better oh crap
i'm bringing in lieutenant eric stevens
the navy seal who saved my life as stark
industries new chief security officer
it's supposed to be my promotion
someone tells me eric's gonna be more
effective
unit was stationed 400 clicks away if
you're trying to imply that he had
advanced knowledge of the attack she'd
be right i uncovered plans to
assassinate tony stark while on a deep
cover operation inside the 10 rings
that's gonna be a wrap on this you'd
like that wouldn't you because those
plans were bankrolled by stark industry
ceo obadiah
i brought receipts
wire transfers bank documents phone
records google it i just dropped it all
online
i knew it
security honors i owe it all to you and
that's why i want you by my side 24 7 as
my new c.o.o
wow wow
i need a killer figurative one of course
but hey a literal one can't hurt either
killers
oh god
pepper's looking buff
a lot of people come around looking to
get their moment in the sun with tony
stark and it's my job to sniff out
exactly what it is they want with them
and what do you smell nothing and that's
the problem
everyone wants
something yeah
lambo that's 3d printed oh man repulsor
trying to miniaturize the jericho into a
portable firearm
that she popped whoa
i come in peace what did your old man
used to say that's right peace means
having a bigger stick than the other guy
he's a friend a lot of good it did dear
old dad what about you you close with
yours nah he died too i developed plans
for automated combat drone thought i was
going to make human soldiers obsolete if
i could never crack the interface
let's build your science fair project
jarvis search the mit doctoral thesis
database project liberator you got an
ear for branding that
wow uh bulk design choice what i like
anime yeah i was gonna say it looks like
a gundam
gundam model
[Music]
at least they're still putting together
an iron man yeah
real big one
human pilots mean human error but with
jarvis at the wheel drones can react to
stimuli in real time and no one needs to
lift a finger it's like a jaeger but
better
you know we need another power source
hey
if we could miniaturize an arc reactor
oh that's a dumb idea
yeah now you're thinking too bad pops
used up the last of it during the war
not all of it
oh how interesting
where did you get this this kind of
stuff pops up all over the globe you
just gotta have the right hook up i
might have just the guy
ulysses claw oh [ __ ] yes things go south
shareholders are gonna flip unless we
secure some kind of diplomatic cover we
send roadie there he's u.s air force and
he's the company's military liaison
we're all above board i think that's a
great idea excellent
tony would you allow yourself to get
manipulated
now that i know you mean business we can
move on to the good stuff
that's definitely andy search yeah i
love the sound of his voice
uh where did you find all this
what's going on here we've been breached
find them and lock them up killmonger
you got eyes on this
kiltmonger it's the eyes
killmonger on comms are you seeing this
oh
holy [ __ ]
what
oh no
oh this is awesome
the speaking drums
let me take the vibranium back where it
belongs sorry cuz that ain't gonna fly
oh
really wish it didn't have to go down
like this
oh hell no
the sonic taser thing is legit
look at this damn
this i'm really feeling why wear the
uniform of your own oppressors fight for
them you got to be part of the system to
change the system no you could burn it
down
no oh my god
my leaked word of the sale to the
wakandan war dogs
all played out just as you predicted it
would
we better load up the product the door
will be here soon
wow this hits so differently yeah
damn
never play clue with jarvis he sees all
go ahead call the cops
yeah well police are the law i want
justice
i melted down that ring of yours
oh [ __ ] oh
vibranium worked like a charm
dang
to killers
you gotta know that won't work yeah
you designed this thing man
all right
oh my goodness
two deer head orphans trying to do right
by our fathers
they sound the same to me the difference
between
that you can't see the difference
between you and me
could i kill you i shouldn't
you know if you bleed long enough
vibranium spear wakandan issue definite
hit job they won a war so that's what
we'll give them put the liberator drones
into production
here's some gollum
[Laughter]
you telling me this is it wakandans are
full of surprises
it's like you say wakandans are full of
surprises
hey that's like the movie
i brought you the man who stole your
vibranium and murdered your people as
proof of my loyalty to wakanda you are
home but there's no time to rest uncle
war is here
you're suggesting we let the killer
robots into the city that's the only way
to disconnect them from the jarvis ai
after that we'll destroy mastermind over
here what say you general
[Music]
my boy
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow this perfectly constructed war
are you certain about this baba
entrusting our fed to this
outsider he is family open the shields
wakanda
so the rumors are true
[Music]
show them the true might of the us
military uncle close the shields
not a shot fired you'll always have a
home in wakanda
i want a little bit more than that
i want your job
[Music]
oh man
siege
honey stark he must have built a backup
transmitter why would he do that that
man was a villain didn't trust anyone
you guys can still take them on
oh cool you guys here go in the
battlefield general
oh
wow
[Applause]
man killmonger yeah
cool
[Music]
[Music]
watcher looks sad yeah
that's a beautiful shot though
gleaming savior i am a loyal servant of
wakanda your majesty
with this herb
you shall become
the next black oh man it just totally
did it
oh
oh
is the child going to be in there was it
worth it
i did what i had to do for what
a throne for vengeance for my father who
suffered through oppression while you
just sat back and watched you believe
the cure for human suffering is more
suffering the cure is power and now i
have it
power unand can be a very volatile force
cousin i'm here to help miss spots
i knew it he killed tony
mr stock was a genius but he's not the
only genius it appears we have a common
enemy your side and mine refuse to see
it
so let us open their eyes together
heroes
are never really god
they live forever as do the ones they
inspire to carry on the fight
did they do it
did they stop it it seems like it would
be pretty hard still he's got all the
wakandan resources is he content to just
be black panther without murdering
t'chaka
damn that was awful
not the episode it's good episode
episode
circumstances yeah
man
[ __ ]
that one hit one hit ah chadwick one
really hit different that time
yeah
yeah
boy oh boy
all right let's chit chatty
all right well i like that episode i did
that was a good one
it was really
really dark
it was a it was a descent but an ascent
at the same time wow
that was uh
that was fascinating watching the
mastermind of this was like the
mastermind killmonger
and i love how it just like slowly got
darker
as it went and you know it's fun it's
fun to see like some of the things that
toy with here it's like because you
saved tony stark the events of civil war
didn't happen
so t'chaka
still gets to live
so when
killmonger goes back to wakanda
he is able to meet t'chaka you know
and also like the reversal of
his death moment in black panther when
we're looking at the sunrise
sunset
sunrise sunrise sunrise sunrise i could
be wrong when they're looking at the
sunrise the sun the sun and the sky
they're doing the shot from there
except it's a
triumphant moment for him his victory
moment there
this is so fascinating to see how this
all went down
okay because it was cool to also get
like
who's playing tony stark we have the
credits here yeah uh
mick wingert okay i don't know who that
is
um
so yeah okay that and that wasn't let's
use your ride all right good to know
sometimes it's a little hard to tell
when they're when the when the actors do
accents yeah like this is just a good
impression or is that actually a t-shirt
right this episode is is it's time to
play which voice uh sound alike was your
favorite yeah exactly pepper potts
it was i thought pepper was gonna have
like some
some different triumphant moment you
know yeah didn't really resort to that
she just had good instincts she had good
instincts she knew what was up the way
pepper is
but i like seeing the version of tony
stark as
just
like he was still affected by his
experience in afghanistan
so witnessing that it was you know his
weapons that almost killed him you're
still affected by it he still wanted to
do right technically
but it was interesting seeing like how
he like to me that's an interesting what
if scenario of like oh wow he really
he really is just still like that same
tony stark just with a little bit of a
different twinge to him you know because
he's still trying to do with something
rooted in good you know yeah i mean he
gets saved pretty quick so he gets the
sprinkling of the immediate peril to
temper his uh you know sensibility but
yeah it's still like bigger and better
and more power i still wanted to do
something really dark though yeah in the
end when that moment of
uh that's the law i want justice
which was a really badass moment i
thought like the episode was going to
end right around there and then i was oh
we're only at the halfway point okay
which made it that much more rewarding
but man the whole thing with t'challa
that stuff just
because of the fact that he's actually
not chadwick boseman is actually dead in
real life
just like
watching like t'challa die and then them
having like you don't see a full-on
funeral but then he's in uh the
afterlife plane that happens i i forget
what that actual section is called
forgive me
but seeing him there it's it it is uh
there's something that this show has
really done with chadwick boseman has
have so many moments that just hit so
different and feel a little bit like
surreal and uncanny due to the fact that
he is actually dead and like wow wow
that's like the ghost of t'challa here
talking to us it's uh
and like what was the line he had about
like the the power of power and end and
basically how it like corrupts you and
all that yeah yeah i couldn't recite it
verbatim
um damn yeah it just hits in different
fields and this time around yeah oh yeah
and the way he gets to deliver that like
it is so many of his lines in this
episode are delivered with this
very
uh sort of lilting poise like he's not
in a hurry to get any of the lines out
and because they are especially on the
spirit plane
so kind of resonant it does feel like
he's piercing beyond the show like just
feel like they've immortalized him in a
different way here
yeah and it's funny to me that he is
like the most frequently appearing
character across the series so far it
was an exciting moment when black
panther shows up because you know i
actually i don't know about you i didn't
expect it i didn't expect him to appear
at all no so when he did i was like oh
this is like a badass moment right here
and he gets killed right away and i'm
like oh [ __ ] that really hurts
that that really really hurt that time
around
because i mean because it's like the
after the all the struggle of black
panther which makes such quick work of
him
and it's it hurts because yeah it's like
you look watch killmonger with all the
obstacles removed from him and all the
means
presented
and yeah it's like black panther isn't
even a match for him i love how
killmonger saved
tony stark he pretty much wraps up a lot
of iron man one in like two minutes
well that's it oh but stan's the one
responsible he's the one who hired him
yeah
well that's that's something else is
like tony stark i thought that was i
appreciated that ultimately as i mean
tony's the title is what if you know
eric killmonger saved tony stark but
this killmonger's episode threw it
through like their buddy thing ends and
turns and i thought that was something
that helped this episode to kind of take
on an extra caliber
because uh you know like in the previous
ones there have been times when we were
like i wish there was a little more time
for this or that but in this episode
that turn where it's like their
relationship comes to an end and and
even tony for whatever bond they have is
not immune from killmonger's master plan
like that
that
sort of crossed the line it felt like
almost and tony is more of just an
object or more of a means to an end in
this episode than like a full-on
you know partner to him by the end uh
well i loved
why they pair
thematically why they paired them up
because
i didn't uh
i found myself going like what's the
point of killmonger and tony like what a
what an interesting pairing like they of
course they never shared the screen
together in the live action format
and so i kept wondering like what is the
deal with like have why specifically
them because you're right i was like
okay is this more going to be tony
stark's episode or killmonger's episode
and uh or is it just going to be both of
them the whole time
but that line that he does have where
he's basically saying to killmonger that
my dad uh our dads both died we're
trying to do right by our dead fathers
like oh that's true that's true they do
have that in common
hey they do have that in common and has
sent them down some very fascinating
paths
uh along the way
there you go man it is kind of
there's something kind of cool about
watching killmonger's rise to power
just
he is a mastermind and that's something
that maybe it is not the takeaway for
people who watch
black panther some people might not walk
away going mastermind criminal when he
is it's always been there well he's
globally minded too like i believe that
he would have an eye on all of these
economical political happenings i think
what makes it interesting is because
michael b jordan is not
this is not an alternate take of him
this is just
his killmonger was just starting at a
different point of time obstacles
i mean it's just different obstacles
he's just at a different point in time
of when his journey to overtaking begins
it's like instead of starting at the
point he does in black panther he starts
with saving tony stark
but it's the same killmonger it's the
exact same version same motives same
reason for the motives same backstory
it's like ever like uh like you know
this version of tony stark is an
alternate version
this is pretty much the same guy yeah
yeah
yeah and uh so that's why i love
watching
what he was doing he was like oh man if
this guy just started like a few movies
earlier you would
[Music]
have taken over and they sell you on
that because you get to watch the way
people
react to
react to him react to his plans react to
his suggestions
react to his motives and actions you get
to watch that all unfold and then
this to me felt like they really
they really honored the live-action
portrayals of how these characters are
like this felt very much like pepper
potts
uh like she would be suspect
you know like right down to like
christine everhart uh in the beginning
of iron man one she says doesn't trust
him doesn't trust her right away so like
she wouldn't trust christine eberhard
why would you trust this guy
you know like there's always a motive
because she can't find anything dirty on
the guy so i i like
that approach
everyone from
wakanda the way they're reacting to him
you're like oh yeah under a set of
different circumstances
it might be receptive to
having him welcome in here yeah and uh
but shuri not trusting
like that's that lines up with her
character too
i thought it was cool that ramonda we
gotta see angela bassett's character
yeah we got us is she talking here yeah
she does she's a little cool
just a few lines um
but uh yeah having uh ramonda being here
was it was awesome because we got to see
her actually kick a bunch of ass
where she doesn't get to do that in the
la maybe she won the sequel but not on
this one but in the in the live action
movie she didn't get to do anything but
like ask a curry
i'm thinking
uh i've seen the movie like three times
i can't remember now if i no i don't
yeah i don't think she does at least in
a featured way i feel like they often
cut back to her for the the motherly
gravitas whereas here yeah it was like
like in some of the coolest looking
action moments were you know those for
her out on the battlefield or i mean
also too like when killmonger is just
like
charging through that group of machines
yeah like there's so many great little
battle moments but i did appreciate that
because she's ramona showed up at least
once before this and and never spoken
that didn't speak to you i'm glad
sherry i think shuri yeah yeah and i'm
glad at least angela bassett got to come
and do a little bit for this because her
moments at least had presents yeah even
if they were brief then andy circus
returning as ulysses claw
i'll listen to him do that character all
day it's like the events of age of
ultron didn't happen so he got to keep
his arm yeah
so his name is les punny because this is
this is rewriting directly from the the
start of the mcu well the real start is
like captain america the first avenger
but you know what i mean the first movie
yeah
so yeah
it's uh but yeah they're rewriting from
that point
and so it's interesting to see all these
the how
things did not happen for these
characters
so they didn't get to evolve to this
point which makes it a easier advantage
for killmonger to take them on
killing freaking
oh dude that whole thing about you know
like you got to be a part of the system
change the system and that was savage
man i thought it was really clever how
he uh you know creates the
what do they call the robots
oh they had two
he creates the stark bots
and then i loved how it just took a
wildly different turn with them entering
into wakanda
and how he used that to manipulate the
situation even more like it's really it
was you really got to see the clever
mastermind of killmonger well they kept
at least for me
even though michael real quick michael
before i forget michael b jordan did a
great job yeah the voiceover work yeah
great job and it was cool to hear like
scenes again like new scenes with
chadwick boseman and michael b jordan
yeah directly interacting yeah i wish i
remember that line off the top of my
head because i loved their exchange
together
and uh about power and end yeah you know
to the effect that you're blinded by
your power yeah you know humanity beyond
it but um
yeah uh oh it'll corrupt you on this
plane or or something oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like if it doesn't catch
up with you on one plane it'll catch up
yeah here at the very least yeah yeah we
got the quote in there somewhere
am i
you know your father had a quote he said
about responsibility if you got a lot of
responsibility you know and some power
and then you should be responsible with
the power
but uh and the watchers seem to be like
emotionally affected this time around
like it was interesting how close like
we got really close to him and doctors
in the doctor strange episode like he
really appeared but then the fact that
he started off on this episode and he
was appearing like just in clear sight
yeah talking to us
it's getting me excited for what the
final episode of the season's gonna be
yeah because he just gets closer and
closer when he finally i'm saying when
are you gonna poke through that veil
buddy yeah you know because he seems
also affected and like saddened by
many of these yeah he's like these other
earths suck
yeah i got to watch all this
stuff all day
yeah i had another point but i don't
remember i'm sorry it's my fault i
totally interrupted you because i was
afraid about losing my point
i got really selfish i interrupted
i feel like this will at least i don't
you know wait to the end of the season
to rank them but this is at least in the
top three i think for me
yeah
i quite enjoyed it a lot yeah you know
it's like
what a few minutes have helped to
breathe better absolutely but
surprisingly hit really well yeah
yeah and and it has like it struck a
nice balance of like it wasn't too jokey
there were certain moments that were
amusing but for the most part it took
its premise and and played it straight
that's what it was as i i thought i got
another point
what is it let's hear it
i thought they did a nice job
because killmonger is is in control the
whole time i guess that's what i meant
before and i i i i would like to
re-contextualize it's not yeah there are
no obstacles but it's it's that they're
he's so in control like the lane is so
open for him to swoop in and really play
to the best of his abilities that i feel
like
and i don't exactly know how to describe
it but in a lesser executed episode it
would have been like oh yeah he's just
gonna keep on winning and there's no
tension or drama but this was like
the reversals kept on like hitting me
and i was trying oh damn like you know
he's bringing in the the machines to
have the battle at first and i'm like oh
damn they're good this is gonna be at
least risky because they're gonna have
to have a war oh wait he even planned
this out with the dome and now the
robots don't work well great i can
totally see how his plan oh no he is
gonna have them fight a war like you
know his he seemed like he was thinking
several steps ahead
of what i could crack in the moment of
being enthralled and so that gave it
that extra pop of like damn this guy is
brilliant yeah yeah you know like he's a
formidable physical threat but an even
better like general mastermind you know
yeah it's cool to have it be his whole
episode and really showcases mastermind
qualities because in black panther movie
he
he's in it in the first half but he's
not really prevalent in it till the last
half of that movie you know when he does
kill claw takes him to wakanda that's
when it really becomes the killmonger
show
but
uh the first half he's not in it that
much
so it's cool to just start off there and
have it be the focus because it does
have you kind of going
like it's really an unveiling of him
throughout where you're like no he's the
same guy from the movie yeah because in
the beginning they it's like you can
feel there's something messed up
happening you know you know you can't
really trust this guy
uh because of the affect of knowing who
he is from the movie
because you're like he's gotta have the
same backstory yeah so
it's got to be like a similar type of
deal with the guy but they do a really
good job on endearing you to the bond
between him and tony when they're
working together and building they're
doing such a great job on that yeah
they're doing such a great job on that
they're like maybe he's good maybe
tony's goodness will kind of rub off on
him and they'll both be
yeah
but uh as we all know
not the case
but guys what did you think about this
episode what was the highlight moment
for you that uh that that one this one
struck me a little different yeah you
know what i realized in this universe
tony stark never built this in a cave
well never it's it's not a part of this
world and that's the saddest thing it
was really loud
it's only 1 18
p.m
in the afternoon
when this is posted
all right guys
all right as well subscribe click that
bell hit that like button
happy birthday koi jondro
jan valente
i'm gonna come rescue you i know you're
lost you're in a cave somewhere in the
middle east but it's okay man cause
we're gonna come we're gonna find you
and then we
are gonna enact our master plan
to open the world to tear down borders
to dash the nonsense
one country versus another one class
versus another class we're going to
bring all the people together jm valente
you and me all the resources abundant
and fairly distributed
and then you know maybe we'll build some
robots or something whatever you like
anyway thanks for being pledged that's
the really uh heroic thing here and if
this episode was full of anti-heroes you
know a descent
that's not you buddy you see my
yardstick
[Laughter]
[Music]